ELMIRA BAYRASLI: Good
afternoon, everyone.
It's so good to
be here at Google.
My name is Elmira Bayrasli.
I'm here to talk about my
book, "From the Other Side
of the World, Extraordinary
Entrepreneurs, Unlikely
Places."
It's a book that profiles
seven entrepreneurs
from seven different
countries overcoming
seven different obstacles.
And the journey that
actually took me there
is one that actually did not
start from entrepreneurship.
It started from a place
where I have been passionate
about foreign policy.
And that passion
for foreign policy
very much comes along with
my own personal story.
My parents are
immigrants from Turkey.
They immigrated
from Turkey to here,
to New York City,
where I grew up,
just across the bridge
in Brooklyn, New York.
And as, I think, just both being
here in New York City, but then
also being the
child of immigrants,
you're very much made aware
of the rest of the world.
Always constantly questions
about where are you
from, and making
trips to Turkey,
and really
understanding that there
was a world beyond New York City
and beyond the United States.
And I think that curiosity
took me on a journey
where I was very interested
in international relations
and trying to understand, well,
what were all the problems that
were happening in places like
Turkey, which for a long time
really suffered from a lot
of economic backwardness.
I remember going
on trips to Turkey
as a child where there
were no telephones.
Television would
come on at 8:00 PM
at night, which I thought
was completely bizarre.
There was very bad
infrastructure.
Roads were a lot of dirt roads.
They were single lane roads.
And all of these things
really stood out in my mind.
And so from the
earliest of ages,
I thought, well, how do you
make countries like Turkey
become like the United States?
And so that question right there
itself put me on this journey
where I went and I
studied political science.
I went to NYU where I got a
degree in political science.
Then I did a graduate
degree at Columbia,
where I focused in on
specifically the Middle East.
And I ended up working
at the State Department.
At the time that I graduated
from both NYU and Columbia,
the State Department was
really the only opportunity
that you had to actually,
really work internationally.
Globalization was just
getting off the ground.
There was certainly no internet.
Multinational companies
had not been multinational.
Certainly you could
find Coca-Cola
in Africa, Asia, Latin
America, and the Middle East.
But there wasn't this phenomenon
where companies were actually
doing business in
different places.
And so I took my degrees and I
went to the State Department,
where I actually got
to work on the issues
that I thought really were
going to change the world.
And we hear this word
a lot, especially
in the startup space,
about changing the world.
And I believed that
that could actually only
happen through government,
through working at the State
Department.
And I got to work on things like
Iraq, Bosnia, Rwanda, Kosovo.
And it was a really
eye opening experience
being on the front lines,
and working on those issues,
and developing the policies that
were affecting these places.
And I was so excited about
doing that that I actually
decided in 2002 to pick
up and move to Sarajevo,
where I got to actually
work on the issues
that I was working
on in Washington, DC.
I got a position working at
the Organization for Security
and Cooperation in Europe
, which is the largest
international body with
working in Bosnia-Herzegovina,
working on post-conflict
rehabilitation.
So the OSCE was working on
things like property return,
and rebuilding the
education system,
and working on civil
society development.
And that was just-- I
thought, this was it.
I was on the front lines, and
this is exactly the things
that I wanted to do.
Except when I went out
and I talked to people
throughout the
country in Bosnia,
people always came back
and told me the same thing.
The one thing that they would
remark is, we need jobs.
How can you help us create jobs?
And you hear this
question a lot.
And it's certainly something
that wasn't unfamiliar to me,
having been here in
the United States.
I think we hear about jobs
in political elections a lot.
It's certainly something
that matters to all of us.
But this question
of job creation
and how it matters to
development and countries
like Bosnia, and
really to the world,
really hit home when I actually
went out to Eastern Bosnia
and I came across an older
woman who really, like literally
berated me.
And we were doing a civil
society development project.
And she said to me,
you know, civil society
and these concepts of democracy
and human rights that you talk
to us about, that's
easy for you to talk
about coming from America.
She said, but you don't realize
that our fathers, our husbands,
our sons, our daughters
actually have to leave Bosnia
in order to have a job, in
order to earn some money.
They're leaving.
And when they leave,
we can't actually
repair anything that
has happened here.
So can you think about how
can you help us create jobs?
And that really spoke to me.
And I thought, well, OK.
Well, how do you create jobs?
I had no idea.
I hadn't thought
about business at all.
The internet had just-- it
had exploded in popularity.
And I thought, OK, well
certainly technology
has to be a part of this.
And so I embarked
on this journey
to find out how do
you create jobs.
Now, I think when everybody
thinks about creating jobs,
they think about
starting a business.
And this word entre-- I
had heard about this word
entrepreneurship.
And entrepreneurship has
certainly become popular.
In fact, I actually think
it's become this big trend
that everybody has romanticized.
And I had just assumed that
if you were an entrepreneur,
you were small business.
And I thought, OK, well, let's
figure out how to do this.
I came back to the United States
and I started on this journey
about how am I going to
learn about doing this?
And I started working at
a nonprofit organization
headquartered here in
New York City that works
with entrepreneurs globally.
And one of the countries
that they work with
is Turkey, which is a country
that I know quite well.
And I started working
at this organization,
helping them with their
media and communications,
with their writing, which is
something that I excel at,
so I wrote a book.
But I hadn't known anything
about entrepreneurship
and what it really was.
To me, entrepreneurship
was you set up
a business, you raise some
money, and that was about it.
That's kind of what encapsulated
what entrepreneurship is.
My aha moment, and one
of the first lessons
that I want to share
with you-- so I
want to share with you four
takeaways from my experience
of writing this book.
My aha moment came when I
actually went to Turkey.
And I had gone to Turkey, and
I went out to Eastern Turkey
to a city named Kars, which
is on the border of Turkey
and Armenia.
And I went out to Kars after
reading Orhan Pamuk's book,
"Snow."
Orhan Pamuk is a Nobel
laureate, and he wrote this book
"Snow" that's set in Kars.
Set in the 20th century.
It's a love story.
I highly recommend it.
But in the book, he talks
about how backwards Kars is.
And he talks about
the dirt roads
that I remember as a child.
And he talks about
a wood block press
that the local newspaper
in Kars was using up
until about early 2000.
And I had an opportunity
to actually talk
to Pamuk about this.
And I thought, as a writer,
the way that you describe this
and you use that detail
of this newspaper press,
it was so brilliant that
you put that in there,
because it really gave
you a sense of how
backward this place is
when the rest of Turkey
has become so commercialized.
It's become so advanced.
Turkey has become a member
of the most powerful
global economies in the world.
And he said, I didn't
actually make that up.
That's actually true.
You should actually go
see it so I decided,
OK, I'm going to go
out to Kars and I'm
going to go see this
wood block press.
So I go out to Kars.
I arrive in the second
closest city to Kars,
because there were no
direct flights at the time.
And it's about a two hour
drive from Erzurum to Kars.
So I don't arrive in Kars
until about midnight.
I speak Turkish, and if
anybody knows anything
about Turkish culture, it's
a very conservative culture
where men and women are, for
the most part, segregated.
There are certain notions
about a woman's place
and what is proper.
And so for me to show
up as a Turkish woman
at this hotel, which is a
dilapidated hotel-- paint
was peeling.
There were a bunch
of moustached men
sitting in the lobby
smoking their Marlboros.
And there's this silence when
I walk in and I ask for a room.
Because what would a
proper Turkish girl
be doing arriving
in Kars at midnight?
What possibly could she want?
And so the hotel clerk
was actually very curious
about what I was doing there.
And I just kind of
dodged his question.
I got the key to my
room and I went up
and settled into my room.
But of course, I couldn't sleep.
And I decided, OK,
I'm going to log
what I'm writing, because
this is going to be
my big literary adventure.
I'm going to go on the
treck of Orhan Pamuk,
and I'm going to
record what I'm doing.
And I pop open my laptop
and I start writing.
And then all of a sudden, a
thing comes up on my computer
and says, choose the Wi-Fi
network of your choice.
And I thought, Wi-Fi?
How in the world does
this place have Wi-Fi?
It's such a-- I just
didn't expect it.
It was such a-- it was
in the middle of nowhere
and so I hadn't expected it.
And I was so excited
that I wanted to run down
and say, like to talk
to the front desk clerk.
So I ran out into the hall
and I looked at the Wi-Fi.
and i noticed that it was made
by a company called AirTies.
AirTies is a wireless
router company
that also makes
wireless routers,
but it also makes set-top boxes.
And the founder is a
Turkish entrepreneur
who spent most of his
most of his career
actually in Silicon
Valley working
on microchips and hardware
for wireless communication.
And I was so excited about this.
So the next morning
I go back down,
and the desk clerk,
again, he's very curious.
He's pressing me, and
he's talking to me
like, what are you doing here?
And what are you
trying to find here?
And I said, you know, actually,
I have a question for you.
I'm really impressed
that you have Wi-Fi.
And he looked at me, and
all of this curiosity
turned into such enthusiasm.
And he said to me, oh, my god.
He said, do you know that
the Wi-Fi is made by a Turk?
And I thought, oh, my god.
How did he know that a Turk
is behind this company?
And I was taken aback.
And he started talking about
Bulent, and Bulent's story.
He said, yes.
He said, it's AirTies.
And apparently, he
said to me, this man
was living in the United States.
He had immigrated from
Turkey to Silicon Valley.
He said, he came back to
Turkey to create this company.
He said, can you
bill believe that?
And I thought to myself, I
hadn't really thought about it.
And what I told him
is I can't believe
that you're telling me this.
And he said, you know, he
said, our country is changing.
He said, I can't believe that
this man would come back here
to start this company.
He said, I think I'm going
to go and study engineering.
And I'm going to think about
starting a company here.
To me, that was my
aha moment where
I realized this is what
entrepreneurship is about
and what people are
getting excited about.
Because I grew up
going to a Turkey
where everybody wanted to leave.
Everybody either
wanted to go to Europe
or everybody wanted to come
here to the United States.
And you know why they wanted to?
Because there were no jobs.
My parents came to
the United States
because they needed jobs.
And my father came here to
actually be an entrepreneur.
And here was a young
person in the eastern part
of the country
where there aren't
a lot of job opportunities, but
he was excited at the prospect
that he could
actually create them.
And I thought, well, here is
why everybody's getting excited
about entrepreneurship,
because it allows
people to gain control
of their own income
and their own future.
So I thought, OK.
Well, here is what
the answer is.
And so I set about my
journey to find out, well,
what is happening
around the world,
and how are
entrepreneurs doing it?
Because when you think
about entrepreneurship here
in the United States, you
automatically think of Google.
You think of the technologies
that have come out
of Silicon Valley.
You think of the icons, not only
of Larry Page and Sergey Brin,
but you think about Steve Jobs.
You think about Mark Zuckerberg
and you think about Facebook.
And you think about all these
big technology companies.
When you say the word
entrepreneurship,
whether it's in a
place like Turkey
or whether it's in Africa,
Asia, or Latin America,
entrepreneurship on
a different notion.
It takes on this notion
that people are just
doing something small.
I think microfinance
has become very
associated with entrepreneurship
outside of America.
And it's this sense
that if you're
outside of the
United States, you're
only doing something micro.
You're starting a business,
and that's really about it.
There's no talk of innovation.
There's no talk of
venture capital.
this word scale.
And there's certainly no
talk of this word unicorn
or technology.
And I thought, well certainly,
Bulent saw something in Turkey
when no one else did.
He started his company in 2004.
And you have to
remember, technology
has really expanded
in the decade
since Bulent
started his company.
And when you talk
about technology
in a place like Turkey
today, it's not so unusual.
But in 2004 it was.
Turkey had not really become
the economic power it had.
And so why did he
take that risk?
Why did he recognize
that he could actually
build a scalable
company that has
received a considerable
amount of investment?
So I decided to go
around the world
and really understand what has
been holding entrepreneurs back
everywhere else in the world.
And what I came
across is this concept
that obstacles are really key.
So we talk about talent and
we talk about innovation,
but that's not something
that we in the United States
have a monopoly on.
I actually have to
say, I think that there
are talented and innovative
people all around the world.
But what's been holding them
back has been obstacles.
Now, every entrepreneur
faces obstacles
in starting his or her business.
But the seven that I actually
focus in on in my book
are ones that I found to be
true throughout every single one
of these countries.
And ones that certainly
are starting to pop up here
in the United States.
So I look at the
lack of talent, where
there's a lack of skill talent,
lack of managerial talent.
I look at poor infrastructure.
That's certainly something that
has held a lot of countries
back, where the
electricity doesn't work
and the roads are bad.
I take a look at the lack of
collaborative space, which was
an interesting insight for me.
And I'll talk a little bit
about that in just a bit.
I also take a look at
the role and effect
that monopolies
and big businesses
have had on the
ability for people,
whether it be in
Mexico or Nigeria,
to be able to start businesses.
Established businesses
preventing others
from actually scaling up.
I take a look at
corruption and the effects
that corruption have on
the ability of people
to start and scale
their businesses.
I take a look at
the rule of law.
And we actually don't really
consider the law and regulation
and the justice system
as being a key component
of entrepreneurship,
but it really is.
And the last thing I look at
is the status quo, and how
the status quo is actually
really a huge obstacle, not
only around the world,
but it's actually
becoming a really big obstacle
here in the United States.
And so I look at
these obstacles,
and certainly, my obstacle
of poor infrastructure,
I think, it was where
do I start with that?
And where I actually did start
with that is I went to Nigeria.
And here was the interesting
thing that I came across.
I went to Nigeria where I think
Africans have long struggled
with poor infrastructure,
whether it be corroded bridges
and poor portways, bad roads.
And I thought, well, here
is one of the things that's
really holding Africans back,
and particularly in Nigeria.
So I went around in Nigeria and
I talked to a lot of people.
And one entrepreneur
that I actually
came across, Tayo Oviosu.
He runs a company called Paga.
Paga is a mobile
payment company.
And I was talking to Tayo
about how do you overcome
this problem of infrastructure.
It's really one of the
challenges, don't you think,
that's holding Nigeria back,
it's holding Africa back.
And Tayo being the gentleman
that he is, he nodded to me.
And I kind of understood
from his nod, it's just like,
oh, here's this
white girl in Africa
and she thinks she actually
knows what our problems are.
And what I didn't realize
is that I didn't really
understand what the
problems in Nigeria were.
So poor infrastructure
is certainly
something that's
held Nigerians back.
But it was only spending
time with Tayo--
and here is my second
point, my second aha moment.
My second revelation is
that what you might think
is a problem might
only be a symptom.
And entrepreneurs, the
really successful ones,
aren't the ones that actually
go after the symptom.
They're the ones who are
actually digging down deep,
really understanding what the
challenges in their communities
are and solving
that true problem.
And I realized this when I
actually went with Tayo around
to understand how his
company Paga works.
Everybody's excited
about digital payments
around the world, mobile money.
The mobile phone, in particular,
when you talk about Africa,
everybody is excited
about the potential
that the mobile phone has
to help Africans leapfrog.
Because they had bypassed
the Industrial Revolution,
but to actually leapfrog
and build their economies
and really become part of
this globalized 21st digital
economy.
And for the most
part, mobile money
has helped Africans and
Nigerians a tremendous amount.
One of the challenges
that you have in Nigeria
is that a majority of people
don't have access to banks.
And so this concept of people
holding onto money where
there's-- you have the
cliche of, I store my money
in my mattress.
That happens to actually be
true for most people in Nigeria.
They don't have access to banks.
The number of banks,
particularly in rural areas,
is very, very low.
So people are literally
holding onto hordes of cash.
They either have it at home or
they have it on their person.
And what happens in a
situation where you're actually
holding onto this
money is that you're
creating a tremendous
amount of insecurity.
But what I also
realized is that when
you're holding onto
a lot of this cash
is that you're actually not--
cash becomes transactional.
And you're not using money
as an asset to be invested.
So people either want to
have it or get rid of it.
They don't want to hold onto
it and go back into the society
where it's actually
going into things
like the development of
roads, or the improvement
of electricity, and the
cleaning up of the streets.
Now, certainly
there's other factors
involved in trying to have
those things move forward.
But what Tayo
actually tapped into,
which a lot of other people
across Africa have tapped into,
the key for mobile money,
is that the problem
in a place like Nigeria
is when people are holding
onto that money and money
is not building as an asset,
and it's not being
leveraged, it's
creating the problem
of poor infrastructure.
So the real problem
in Nigeria is a lack
of a financial infrastructure.
This lack of a
financial framework
where actually people could
store their money safely, take
it out, and for it to build.
So that people can save,
and they can invest,
and they can do all
of these things.
And I realized that, not
only in talking to Tayo,
but seeing how this mobile
money payment system works.
And the way it works
is I can send you
a payment, phone to phone, and
we have those services here
in the United States.
But here in the
United States, it's
just an electronic transaction.
So it goes from me to
you, and then you to me,
or I can pay my Uber, or
I can pay for my lunch.
And that's it.
In a place like
Nigeria, there's still
the problem of cashing
in and cashing out,
because you still
have to remember
there's this lack of banks.
And so they have all of these
agents around in the country.
There's thousands of
agents that Paga uses.
People who run storefront shops.
People who are
selling newspapers.
People who are selling t-shirts.
People who are
selling groceries.
And these people act as
cash in and cash out points.
And what I actually realized
is that these individuals
are starting to
actually create what
would have been bank branches
and an infrastructure
to allow people to
actually store their money
and keep it safe.
And they're helping
to solve this problem
of a lack of a financial
infrastructure in very
incremental ways.
I think there are a lot of still
challenges with mobile money,
where it still doesn't allow
people for the opportunity
to take out loans and to
create an insurance system.
And there's still other
elements of financing
that people haven't really
considered that banks do
and a financial system does.
But really spending
time with Tayo
made me realize that
entrepreneurs are not
individuals who are simply
setting up a business
to get money.
They're actually
solving a core problem
and addressing an
issue that's changing
the socioeconomic landscape
in their countries.
They're making it
possible for people
to move into either the middle
class or move forward further.
And that is kind of what
the big differentiator
of an entrepreneur is from
a small business owner
or somebody who opens up just
a diner or a mom and pop shop.
So I take this knowledge
and I'm excited.
I'm like, OK, so now I
kind of really get this.
So entrepreneur is
not a small business.
They're solving problems.
They're moving the
needle forward.
And so I go to India.
And I go to India and I
come across an entrepreneur
named Shaffi Mather.
Shaffi Mather started a
for-profit ambulance company
in Mumbai.
And I thought,
well, I really want
to talk to this guy Shaffi,
because who in the world
would start a for-profit
ambulance in Mumbai.
That just sounds like
there's a good story there.
And there is, because
Shaffi started this company
not because he was a
doctor, not because he
was working as a paramedic.
He actually had no background
in health care whatsoever.
His mother, one night after
he and his family had dinner,
started choking.
And they all started to panic.
They didn't know what to do.
Nobody knew what the
Heimlich maneuver was.
She was choking, she
was gasping for air.
So what Shaffi did
was he did something
that I think any of us
here in this room would do.
He picked up the phone to call
India's equivalent of 911.
Except no one picked up
the phone on the other end.
The phone kept
ringing and ringing.
And after a few minutes,
which is actually
a considerable amount
of time when someone
is in a distressed situation,
as Shaffi's mother was,
he hung up.
And he decided, I'm
going to take my mother,
I'm going to put her
in my car, and I'm
going to rush her
to the hospital.
She was OK, but
that event really
shook Shaffi to the core.
And he thought,
here I am-- Shaffi
was a management consultant
in one of the big consulting
firms in Mumbai.
And he had studied business
here in the United States.
He had gone to school in the UK.
And he'd been interacting--
he travels globally, right?
He's a management consultant,
so he's interacting
with people around the world.
And everywhere he
went, everybody
kept talking about how
India is the Asian tiger.
India is one of the
most powerful economies
in the world.
We have to pay attention
to what India is doing.
India's needed.
It's become one of
the go-to countries
that if you want to talk to the
big players around the world,
you go and you talk to India.
And he thought,
how can we actually
be this global power
that everybody's
talking about when we can't
even call for an ambulance?
And he thought about this.
And he consulted
with his friends.
And they thought,
OK, why don't we
try to actually see
if we can repair this?
He went and he talked to
people in the government
to see if they would
actually do something
about the ambulance service.
And when they didn't,
Shaffi decided,
you know what, everybody's
doing these social enterprises.
People are talking
about entrepreneurship.
I'm going to do
something about this.
I'm going to solve this
problem of a lack of ambulance
and emergency care in India.
I'm going to start
with Mumbai and I'm
going to see where it goes.
So he takes a year off.
He goes to London, and he spends
time with the London ambulance
service.
He learns everything
there is to know
about emergency care, which is
a lot of it is about logistics.
And he works with the
London ambulance service.
And he manages to get
a number of ambulances
donated to him in Mumbai.
He comes to New York and he has
meetings with various hospitals
here.
And he gets people to
volunteer and he gets donations
from them.
He goes back to Mumbai.
He raises some
money to hire staff.
And he puts all the
elements of what
he thinks this is going to solve
the problem in India-- he's
going to solve this one problem
of a lack of a functioning
emergency care service,
at least in Mumbai.
So what's the last
part that he needs?
He needs a phone number
that people can call.
He can't have a number
like 911 because those
are government numbers.
And because he's going to
run a for-profit company,
he needs a different
kind of a number.
And they have special
numbers like that
for individuals in India.
They're four digit numbers.
He goes to register for this
number and he gets sent around.
And he knew-- he
told me, he said,
I knew that this would happen.
He said, I grew up in India and
there's a lot of bureaucracy.
There's a lot of people telling
you to go to this office
and go to that office.
He said, so I had expected this.
But after three
months, it started
to become tiresome having
to go from office to office.
Finally, he's told that if
he wants that special number
that's given to nonprofit
organizations, then
he needs to go to New Delhi.
He needs to go to
the capital of India
and he has to register with the
Ministry of Telecommunications.
So he goes off to
the capital of India.
And he finally finds
the guy where he's
going to get the phone number.
And the guy says, I
have great news for you.
I'm going to give you a
really terrific phone number .
It's going to be one that
it's going to be easy
for you to reach people.
People are easily going to
remember this phone number.
So Shaffi says,
that's fantastic.
This is all falling into place.
This is all going to work.
Everything is going
to move forward.
And the bureaucrat says how
much is it worth to you?
He asked Shaffi for the
equivalent of 4,000 US dollars.
Now, Shaffi wasn't
surprised, again,
that this bureaucrat was
asking for what Shaffi he told
me was chai pani.
Chai pani is money for tea.
And it's something
that a lot of people
in India, but particularly
bureaucrats, ask for.
The concept, you know,
you give a couple
of rupees and your paperwork
moves along a little quicker.
And it actually
dawned on me when
he was telling me the
story about chai pani,
that that word to
grease a palm, it
must emanate from this concept
of trying to actually move
things along a lot quicker.
There's really nothing
sinister in it.
I think we do that here
in the United States
where we pay extra money
for expedited services.
What he was shocked by was
this exorbitant amount of money
that he was being asked for.
And he certainly said,
sir, that's certainly
really unreasonable for
you to be asking that.
And the bureaucrat said,
no, if you don't pay me
the equivalent of
4,000 US dollars,
I'm not going to give
you the number you want.
That was the aha
moment for Shaffi.
And when he was telling
me this, I actually
went back to what I remembered
about this problem in Nigeria
where if you're an
entrepreneur and you're only
focused on solving a
symptom, you're not really
addressing the problem.
And Shaffi sat there and
he thought, oh, my god.
What have I done?
I have done all of this work.
I have raised all of this money.
And I'm about to launch
this startup that
is supposed to address this
problem of emergency care
in India, when the
problem in India
is actually not
about emergency care
and the capabilities
of us doing this.
The problem is trust.
The problem in
India is that there
is this level of corruption.
And that there is
this expectation
that bureaucrats
will ask people who
are coming to them, either
for a license or an approval
or a patent or whatever it is,
and that people will pay this.
And people in India, they don't
believe in the public services.
They don't believe that their
elected officials can actually
deliver on the promises
that they have made.
Or fulfill just basic
services and needs,
such as ambulance
care, or whether it's
operating the trains
or the buses on time.
And he though, that is actually
the problem here in India.
And I'm addressing
the wrong issue.
How do I build trust?
And so that was the third
takeaway, which is Shaffi's,
was this concept of trust.
But this is the one
thing that entrepreneurs,
really successful ones, do.
And it's what
distinguishes them.
They develop trust
within the community.
And Shaffi thought,
well, how do I do that?
And as he was
talking about that,
he thought about
the great companies
in Silicon Valley, particular
companies like Google.
And he thought,
what are they doing?
They're reaching out to people,
they're listening to people.
And they're connecting
with people.
They're building community.
How can I do that now, now
that I've started all this?
And at that moment,
Shaffi thought, OK, here
is what I'm going to do.
Rather than actually focusing
in on this concept of emergency
care and the lack
of ambulances, I'm
going to go out and
tell this story.
So he looks at the
bureaucrat and he says,
I will not pay you that $4,000.
And the bureaucrat
says, OK, dude.
No problem.
Here's a number.
I'm going to give
you the number 1298.
Now, if you think
about it, 1298 is not
a very memorable combination.
You know, it's not something
you would actually remember.
Shaffi decided that he was
going to take that number,
and instead of actually going
out and promoting the fact
that he has this ambulance care
that will answer your emergency
phone number, he
was going to go out
and he was going to tell
the story about what
happened to him in that office.
And he was going to talk
to Indians about the fact
that the reason that we're
not able to actually move
public services forward
is not because we're not
capable of it.
Because we lack so much trust.
And we're going to
build this trust up.
And that is how India is
going to fulfill his potential
as this great global power.
He went out with that message
and it resonated with people.
People started
using the service.
More states in India requested
Shaffi and this company, 1298,
to actually come and roll
out ambulance services
in their state.
1298 now operates in all
of the states within India.
And it's actually exported its
model to places like Singapore
and to Dubai.
And I thought, OK, well this
is a great example of here
are the lessons
for entrepreneurs.
And so off I went, and I
thought OK, well, here I
am in India and looking
at this concept of trust.
How do you build trust in
a country like Pakistan?
In a country where
there's tremendous amount
of insecurity, and
when you turn on CNN,
there are all
these horrible news
reports about how there
are these bombings.
And then just this
morning there was
a gunman who killed people at a
university campus this morning.
How do you actually build
trust in a situation like that?
How do you even start a company
in such an insecure place?
And I went to Pakistan,
and I spent time
with a number of
tech entrepreneurs.
And there's actually
quite considerable number
of technology-based
entrepreneurs
in Lahore and in Karachi.
And I spent time
with Monis Rahman,
who runs a company
called Naseeb Networks.
Naseeb Networks has
two online platforms,
the one being a dating
website, because you know,
if you're an entrepreneur,
why not start a dating website
in Pakistan?
The other one is a jobs website.
And the jobs website
was started as a result
of the success of the
dating website in Pakistan.
Because people
want to find love.
And when I spent time
with Monis and understand
how does his technology company
work, what I actually realized
is how you build trust in
a country like Pakistan,
and how do you address
this issue of insecurity,
was one of many of the
aha moments I have.
But the one that I'll
end on is this concept
of the importance of space.
And what Monis talked
about was, he said,
the problem in Pakistan is
that there is this perception
that there is only
one narrative.
That it's all about insecurity.
When insecurity and this problem
of terrorism and violence
in this country is
only about 5% of what
happens here in Pakistan.
The rest of it doesn't
actually get translated.
And I said, but then
how do you actually
get people to actually talk
about what is going on?
He said, well, that's one
of the reasons I started
the companies that I did.
He said, I came
back to Pakistan--
he went back to Pakistan
from Silicon Valley.
He was working at
Intel where he was
working on building microchips.
And he left that
job, much like Bulent
left Silicon Valley
to go back to Turkey,
because he saw an opportunity
where the internet was
going to change things.
Technology itself is not
the one big factor that
is helping people
start companies,
but it's helping
change perceptions.
And what he saw was one of
the challenges in Pakistan
was not only geographically
is the country divided,
because it's in
such rough terrain.
So the country is divided into
these four different regions
and these four
different tribal groups.
And to get from point A to
point B is very difficult.
The country does suffer from
a lot of poor infrastructure,
but there is just
not a lot of people
being able to come
together to share ideas.
There's also the
challenge in Pakistan
where men and women are
segregated a lot of the time.
There are very few forums
for people to actually come
together in Pakistan.
And those few forums are
really-- they are for men.
You have the
military where people
are able to come together.
You have the cricket
field where people
are able to come
together for games.
And then there's the university
campus, but not a lot of people
have access to
university campus.
And so he thought,
well, here the internet,
everybody is getting
on the internet.
This is going to be the
one medium that's actually
going to be able to
get all Pakistanis
on the same platform.
So rather than wait for a lot
of these Silicon Valley-based
companies to come
to Pakistan, I'm
going to bring these forums
to Pakistan for Pakistanis.
And what I actually
realized in him
doing that is he's
helping to actually change
the perceptions, not
only among Pakistan,
but the greater world,
about what Pakistan is.
And as a result of
what Monis did in 2004,
and what has
happened since then,
is that he's been able to create
this entire community of people
who are coming together to
build platforms on the internet,
but also get people in Pakistan
excited about entrepreneurship.
Space continues
to be a challenge
for countries like Pakistan.
And certainly, that's something
that needs to be addressed,
because you can't
just build companies
and interact with each
other just on the internet.
I think here, being in
this building itself,
I think you see the
importance of people
being able to come together to
interact and to share ideas.
And that was one of those
big aha moments I had,
where I actually thought
insecurity was one
of these things holding back.
It was actually the lack
of collaborative spaces.
Because when you
actually think about it,
one of the things
that Monis said to me
is that, if you think
about it, Israel
has an insecurity problem too.
But nobody would actually
say that Israel is not
an innovative place.
And I thought he was right,
because Israel is actually
known as the startup nation.
But in Israel, people are
actually able to come together,
and they're encouraged
to share their ideas.
The last place that I went to
on my journey to write this book
is to Silicon Valley.
And that whole concept
of space was actually
really solidified for me,
and really, it drove it home.
Because when you think
about it, everybody
talks about how do we replicate
the story of Silicon Valley?
How do we create
the next Steve Jobs?
How do we actually
create the next Google?
And it really comes
down to space.
There's a reason that
there is this campus here
and that Google creates these
opportunities for all of you
to come together.
Because ideas are not
created in and of themselves.
This myth that the entrepreneur
sits in a garage by him
or herself, that
is just not true.
All of the great innovations
that have come about
have come about as a result
of people interacting
with one another, and
engaging with one another,
and iterating and building on
the various different ideas
they have.
The secret sauce
of Silicon Valley
that everybody is
trying to unlock
is really not really a secret.
It's actually about community.
And it's the one thing
that actually, I think,
Google has given to the world.
It's been able to
bring people together.
And for people to gather and
interact with one another,
which is one of the
reasons that Google
is one of the most innovative
companies in the world.
And it's one of the
reasons that people
look to it as an example.
And so the secret sauce
of it is about community.
I will end my talk there.
I thank you very much.
And I welcome you to ask
any questions that you have
if you would step
up to the mics.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Is this on?
ELMIRA BAYRASLI: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Evidently is.
Hey, Elmira.
Thanks so much for coming.
I love what you've
been working on.
My name is Bilau.
My family is originally
from Pakistan,
so that last story kind
of hit home with me.
So thinking about enterprise
as a whole and the value
that it brings,
everyone in this room,
I'm sure, being a part of
Google, values enterprise.
But there's increasingly
been this conversation
about how does enterprise
actually trickle down
to the rest of society?
And Oxfam recently
released some numbers
about the gap
between rich and poor
is increasing, even
in the US, well,
especially the US and the West.
So as much as I love enterprise,
do you see in the long run
the value that's being
created by these entrepreneurs
in these developing
countries-- do you
see that having the same issues
that we're having in the West?
Will it eventually trickle down
and build value for society,
or will they just be in
another league, you know,
wealthy, sitting at the top?
ELMIRA BAYRASLI:
Thanks for that, Bilau.
That's a great question.
I actually think
that entrepreneurship
is one of the greatest--
and I say that in my book.
I think that
entrepreneurs have done
more than any
charity, philanthropy,
or nonprofit organization,
or multilateral organization
that I've seen.
Going back to what
I was saying before,
entrepreneurs go in
there and they're really
solving the problems
and challenges
within their community.
I think we want to tear--
there is this tendency
to want to tear down
people in Silicon Valley
and then blame them for
this growing inequality.
I actually think
that those are things
that need to be addressed by
government and on a policy
level.
I think what entrepreneurs are
doing is they are adding value.
And what I said
before is that they're
creating new channels for
socioeconomic creation.
So they're moving
people forward.
So they're not
only creating jobs,
they're creating opportunities.
And they're bringing
investments in.
So whether it's Tayo in
Nigeria or whether it's
Monis in Pakistan, he's
brought in venture capital
money from the United States.
And when you have people putting
those type of investments
there, there is a sense
of not only ownership,
but there's this sense that
you want to actually make
something succeed.
And so there's a
lot of criticism
of people who are
throwing a lot of money
at a lot of technology startups.
I actually think that's
a really great thing.
Does everything work out?
No, and are there cons?
Absolutely.
But I think that
we need to really
be careful about how we
use this word inequality,
and how we throw it around.
And not assign
that responsibility
to the entrepreneurs.
I think that's actually
a responsibility
of people in leadership.
AUDIENCE: Definitely.
All right, great.
Thank you.
ELMIRA BAYRASLI:
No more questions?
OK.
Well, thank you so
much for coming out.
I appreciate it.
Please buy a book.
[APPLAUSE]